[Música]
bienvenidos a enlace cono sur de es de
santiago de chile chile se enfrenta a su
elección presidencial más incierta en
años por primera vez en los últimos 16
años mi sebastián piñera ni michelle
bachelet que alternaron los últimos
cuatro mandatos se presentan en esta
contienda el nuevo ocupante del palacio
de la moneda será por tanto un rostro
desconocido en el panteón de los
presidentes o presidentas chilenas que
deberá enfrentar no pocos desafíos
mientras en el país se trabaja en una
nueva carta refundacional destinada a
erradicar para siempre la herencia de la
dictadura son siete los candidatos que
optan a este puesto cuatro de ellos se
presentaron en elecciones pasadas
analizamos a los cuatro candidatos con
más posibilidades de pasar a segunda
vuelta
la única mujer yasna provoste profesora
ex ministro de educación del primer
gobierno de michelle bachelet y miembro
del pueblo originario de hábitat lidera
la democracia cristiana
el líder estudiantil gabriel boric
representa a la coalición más a la
izquierda del frente amplio que tiene
como aliado al partido comunista su
candidatura es la más cercana al
espíritu del 18 de octubre cuando
explotaron las protestas el otro
candidato fuerte es el miembro de la
ultraderecha josé antonio kast su
discurso coherente e inequívoco
antiaborto profamilia y lleno de
certezas apela a esta derecha que se ha
quedado huérfana en los últimos años en
chile también compite el candidato
oficialista de centroderecha el
independiente sebastián sitges criticado
por que sus campañas anteriores fueron
financiadas por empresas pesqueras y de
gas ambos rubros bajo la sombra de
denuncias del lobby político y
corrupción quien pasará a la segunda
vuelta por primera vez en muchos años
según las encuestas muchos chilenos aún
no han decidido a su candidato para la
votación
y algunas dudas por muchas cosas
entonces por eso que todavía estoy
pensando un poco
no hay una confusión total
entre los desafíos a enfrentar el nuevo
mandatario de mandataria chilena deberá
recuperar una economía golpeada por la
pandemia entre otros problemas como el
descontento social o la inmigración
el candidato ganador enfrentará una
difícil situación económica cuando
muchas familias chilenas tendrán que
sobrevivir sin las ayudas sociales con
las que contaron durante la pandemia que
según cifras oficiales alcanzaron a 14,5
de 19 millones de chilenos además la
economía se ve amenazada por un cuarto
retiro de fondo de pensiones que se
fragua en el congreso- actualmente y que
podría disparar más aún los deteriorados
indicadores como la inflación o las
altas tasas de interés por otro lado las
políticas de la pandemia también han
generado un alto endeudamiento fiscal
que habrá que reducir junto a la
economía si les sigue sufriendo las
consecuencias de un estallido social que
ha normalizado el uso de la violencia y
que todavía muestra un gran descontento
en las calles por las demandas de una
mejor salud educación y pensiones que
dos años después aún no se materializan
el tema de la inmigración no es menos
relevante ha sacudido con fuerza al país
en el norte con la llegada de redes
organizadas de tráfico de personas y un
flujo de inmigrantes constante por el
desierto en su mayoría venezolanos que
caminan miles de kilómetros antes de
atravesar los pasos ilegales en la
porosa frontera del norte
rescatar la confianza en las
instituciones es otro desafío en chile
el presidente sebastián piñera enfrenta
a un juicio político público y una
investigación de la fiscalía por
presuntos delitos de soborno cohecho y
delitos tributarios por el escándalo de
los papeles de pandora
mientras todo esto sucede el otro gran
proceso político que se sigue fraguando
en chile comenzó a debatirse el 18 de
octubre dos años después de la revuelta
social que cambió el país para siempre
155 personas están redactando una nueva
constitución la primera paritaria en el
mundo en donde por primera vez en la
historia política chilena los pueblos
originarios tienen voz y representación
significativa entre los múltiples
cambios que podría traer la nueva carta
magna está reducir el omnipresente poder
actual del presidente así que el próximo
gobierno podría ser uno de transición
hasta que se ponga en marcha la nueva
constitución que establecería nuevos
plazos y formas electorales
hemos hecho un enorme esfuerzo desde la
convención constitucional en una
experiencia inédita
en la historia chilena de construir una
constitución por la vida democrática
amplia plural diversa por primera vez en
la historia de la república en el
sentido de crear un sistema político
crear una nueva institucionalidad un
estado que responda a la diversidad a la
pluralidad de esta sociedad pero que
además de eso dé respuestas efectivas en
términos de resolver las necesidades y
las inequidades todo es posible en este
nuevo chile de hoy más inclusivo moderno
evolutivo cambiante que tiene que dejar
de lado aunque sea temporalmente la
estabilidad la previsión y la seguridad
de la que hizo su bastión en el pasado
hasta aquí esta edición de enlace
conosur desde santiago de chile- los
esperamos en un nuevo programa